but then
towards the end we settled on this
design
so
we did something you're usually not
allowed to do
[Music]
what's up guys i'm kphd here so you may
remember a couple videos ago i was
talking about the ideal budget
smartphone formula and how much
different parts cost relative to the
final cost of the phone
and in that video i actually asked i
called out if any companies want to get
in touch with me and maybe give us the
actual numbers of what some of these
parts actually cost well that would be
great well oneplus as you probably
already know by now is working on and
has been teasing their upcoming
mid-ranger budget phone and they
actually reached out and they said hey
okay we are willing to talk about that
kind of stuff and we can use project
nord as like an example to walk through
that discussion
so i said okay and what followed was
some of the most interesting informative
discussion i've had in the smartphone
world in a long time so i'm speaking
with carl pay one of the co-founders of
oneplus one of the guys you usually see
on stage at their events presenting
stuff and there's a full uncut version
of this entire discussion on the
waveform podcast i'll link it below we
got really in the weeds about product
strategy and the not so linear nature
about how products are planned and how
they come to life in 2020 uh but if you
want to hear all of that you can but
this here is me cherry picking some of
the really good stuff we get actual
numbers and prices we get real
discussions and we got a design reveal
of oneplus nord as promised
enjoy
[Music]
do we need do we need to do that
all right carl thank you for joining me
so i think we're all we're here because
you get you guys are you're working on a
new product line
um
oneplus nord i think all we really know
about it as of right now as we're
recording this is the name is nord and
then there's all sorts of speculation
about what exactly it is
so why don't we just get right into it
and just just tell me what you can about
what oneplus nord is what you've been
working on
what we should know now so um if you
look at the the timing now and if you
look at the industry as a whole
most smartphone companies they really
focus all their time and energy into
creating a great flagship phone the
mid-range category is
it's it's kind of a an afterthought so
the the best and brightest go and make
the flagship phone and the
you know the mid-range it is what it is
um for us we think we're ready now
because
the technology is ready
with the 765g
chipset from qualcomm
we finally feel like the the mid-range
chipset are ready to deliver the
experience that people have come to
expect from a oneplus product so over
the past couple of years you know we've
been
really focused on creating a fast and
smooth experience
and
prior to this this was done on the 800
series
yeah but now um as technology is
improving we feel like it's finally
time and the technology is finally ready
so that now with the 700 series we're
able to deliver that same experience so
when you're scrolling through the the
oneplus nord
you won't actually be able to tell which
platform you're on all the animations
all the
optimizations we've kind of
taken from the 800 series and brought to
the 700 series i'm sure that when they
use it for the first time they won't
really be able to tell what the
um that it's it's not a 800 series
chipset i think they'll be able to tell
once they
get into something really intensive like
a you know 3d game on a higher graphics
setting but for the regular day-to-day
tasks i've been using it as my daily
driver for
quite some time now
you can't really tell so that's what it
is like we finally feel like there's a
opening for us to
take our flagship experience
into a new price category and
we waited a little bit of time until we
were finally ready to deliver this so
i'm always wondering i'm always
wondering how much how much parts cost
in a phone so i was talking about the
sort of formula for a budget phone
um when you end up at a 350 400 450
phone
um what sort of trade-offs like need to
be made because they're simply too
expensive
uh so i have a couple questions
maybe you can answer
about that sure we'll see i'll try my
best so generally about about how much
does it cost to add nfc to a phone nfc
is one of those things we've seen left
out of previous phones previous oneplus
phones for cost reasons now they're in
many phones but still left out
occasionally
what does that
little nfc
tag cost yeah nowadays it's become
really common right so it's not
something we thought of thought about a
lot but it costs around four dollars to
just add the nbc there and that's four
bucks to you the the the manufacturer
that's putting them in
in the phones or four bucks to the end
consumer to you okay it's it's um
yeah when we think about a cup the cost
of a smartphone we talk in terms of bom
bom
it means building materials so the four
dollars gets into the building materials
and then we have other costs to deliver
the phone to the consumer we have
channel cost marketing cost
operational cost offices staff etc so
this is just the cost of components what
about ip certification because that's
not that's not a component necessarily
it's a couple of seals and a couple of
things you add to the phone that
eventually
qualify it for a certification so an
ip68 rating in a phone for example
how much extra does that cost yeah so
this is a really interesting topic and
it's quite complicated so um bear with
me for a little bit
there's no
there's no official kind of body or
third party
organization that certifies
phones to be
ip rated it's just a set of standards
that are you know commonly agreed upon
in the industry so take ip68 for
instance
for a phone to be
able to claim that it's ip68 certified
it needs to survive um
1.5 meters
underwater sorry for um north american
that's fine
for like 10 minutes or something
for uh for 30 minutes 30 minutes okay
for 30 minutes so you mentioned the yeah
we need to add additional seals to make
sure that every port is
waterproof
but that's actually only a very small
part
of the additional cost the
most of the cost here comes from the
from the
machines that we have to buy to test the
devices
so that's the biggest cost driver it's a
big fixed investment to buy all these
machines that allow us to test the
devices through
kind of
blowing air into the ports to see if the
everything comes out it's not tested
underwater so that's the biggest fixed
investment the second cost driver is
actually manpower
so every every phone that's ip certified
needs to undergo testing towards the end
of the assembly line so at the end of
the assembly line we have to add a few
more steps to the process
and this makes the phone
take longer time to manufacture and we
also need more manpower and more people
to
undergo these tests so that's the second
biggest cost driver the
the
seals themselves they don't really cost
a lot so how much so how much do you
save by not having all that obviously
the machines
divide out over you know the cost of
units but
i feel like
if you just put the seals in and toss it
under water and it seems to survive
you're close even though you're not
necessarily testing with official
machines right so
it really depends on the volume right so
if you sell a lot of phones or you
manufacture a lot of phones and you just
divide the cost of machines by a lot of
phones and hence driving the price down
and also if your team is more
experienced in building these assembly
lines that have ip certification tests
you can save time there as well to save
costs
for us it costs around 15
for each phone to
do the ip certification
so for the oneplus nord we we chose to
not do it and as you say we
we can still build a phone that survives
the day-to-day if you spill some water
on your phone if you
um
if you drop it in
a pool of water it still works so
for for the oneplus nord we just decided
that this is not a place
where we should put cost because we're
looking at the overall user experience
we're not
designing for extreme use cases
we're not designing to cover kind of
every corner of the user experience
right so it may
like previous oneplus phones that
weren't certified it may still have the
seals and like you say it might still
survive
a spill or a rain or something like that
but it doesn't necessarily go through
the same
extra steps in manufacturing and testing
with those machines which saves a bit of
money
and therefore
takes the price down a little bit so
with the oneplus nord at every stage of
the product development process we make
sure that the design can withstand 30
centimeters of water for 30 seconds and
after
after testing it in water we weigh it
again so if the weight has increased
there's actually water in the phone and
only when there's no additional weight
can it move on to the next development
process there's another uh trade-off i
guess i'm curious about which is battery
and i think a lot of people don't really
think about the different types of ways
that you can build a battery experience
usually we just think of how big is it
what's the battery life and then that's
the end but there's how fast it charges
how fast it depletes
um how do you decide on a battery in a
phone um i think battery is is pretty
standard but you mess you mentioned
charging right and
our phones have been known to have warp
charging and that that has additional
costs the
hardware is not
exactly the same because it's a high
amperage charging
the power conversion happens in the
power brick instead of in the phone
itself and that has a
some additional cost yeah i mean
shipping a phone with power brick
pretty pretty important some may say um
pretty important
yeah what about uh what about the
display so we've talked about i've
talked about displays a lot i'm i'm
always interested in a great screen
what's the what's the difference between
a great screen and a not so great screen
when you're pricing out like something
like a flagship versus a mid-range phone
um when it comes to display i think the
the biggest choice you have to make is
whether you're using a amoled display or
a lcd display
and
an amoled display is up to two times
more expensive than a lcd display
but
it depends on a lot of other factors as
well so for instance if you want a
curved display
that costs even more because
when um when you're manufacturing these
curve displays
the
there there's more um prone to error in
the manufacturing process so the yield
rate gets lower hence the more expensive
product gotcha and does refresh rate
seem to come down in price a little bit
every year like it was almost unusual to
have a higher fresh rate maybe four
years ago in a phone now it seems like
you can get a high refresh rate amoled
display pretty readily when it comes to
display it's a lot about volume so now
that 90 hertz displays have become
really common that
drives the volume up and then hence the
price down
but it's still
it's still a trade-off because
we spend quite a lot on the display for
this phone to ensure the
smokes uh just to ensure the smooth
scrolling
um
but we think it's worth it i gotta ask i
have to i'm sorry in advance but i have
to ask
how much does a headphone jack cost
uh
good question headphone jack doesn't
cost that much in
in in the bill of materials
the the cost of that comes from the
mechanical design of the phone the
hardware design of the phone it takes
additional space
space you can otherwise use for other
things for instance battery and nowadays
true wireless earphones are getting
pretty popular and they're coming down
in price
so
we see a
smaller and smaller need for headphone
jacks
i'm actually curious how big of a
difference do you think
you actually gain
in battery for example i think that's
usually the cited like biggest
improvement once you get rid of that
port how how much bigger
do you actually get to make the battery
in a phone by getting rid of the
headphone jack it's a overall balance i
think i would say um i haven't really
calculated how much you know that amount
of space
results in a milli amperage for the
battery
but it's a balance of a lot of different
things for instance
we also want to make sure our phones are
not too thick because one of the first
things consumers
react to is how it feels in the hand
and when you have a phone that feels
really slim
or
feels good in the hand so in our case we
also
since the very beginning we have these
tapered edges on the back to make it
more grippable
this is really important so
it's an overall balance a larger battery
or less space for the battery will also
result in a thicker phone so i can just
show you quickly
some of the
the prototypes we
we explored before
um
deciding on their final design
so i have some of them here
so
how should i show them
that's good so that's so this is like a
when you say prototype this is like you
make a sort of a mock-up of a potential
design to fit the phone into yeah um
when i say prototype i mean design
mockups so
as i was saying before when the product
team is kind of working on
their product strategy the industrial
design team is also working on different
paths to take the
design so
all the prototypes all the mock-ups are
actually of they have the same camera
kind of configuration you see a very
unique style camera configuration but
the finish is different here you see
um
like three squares
on the previous one it's the mad frosted
class
and then like
yeah
yeah
which one of these two would you like
the most
i'm gonna i'm gonna go with that dave 2d
teal over there on the side
i feel like i would i would be into that
so this one
yeah
teal
yeah dave 2d2
yeah um
but then
towards the end we settled on this
design
so
we did something you're usually not
allowed to do
which is um we changed design really
late in the process
and that caused the entire project to
be delayed by around a month
and the reason why we did this is
because in the beginning
we saw this
new product line as more of a
test or an experiment
but as we were looking into the
the data and the consumers we realized
that this would be a really good
opportunity that we would sell a lot
more phones than we
you know originally envisioned
so then we had to
really rethink our design strategy
are we doing this as an experiment if
it's an experiment then we can be much
more daring with our industrial design
we can try this uh
camera setup that looks really unique
l-shaped camera setup
but if we want to sell a lot of phones
we want to target a much broader user
base
we need to make sure that it's
immediately recognizable as a oneplus
phone
so we have the same you know camera
setup vertical camera setup you see in
other oneplus phones
and we have the same kind of tapered
edges on the on the back of the phone to
really remind you of the oneplus design
philosophy that reminds me of a question
i've always had
i i am so curious about this so you
you how long before
it's revealed
is the design locked because i'm always
i'm always thinking like sometimes
phones get leaked and then
you know there's all this
this this feedback online suddenly of a
phone that you haven't announced yet and
you have maybe if it's early enough the
ability to react to it but like you said
once you've started manufacturing and
tooling and everything it's it's almost
impossible to
change it without delaying it massively
so so how long before you get on stage
with that final product is the design
finished ideally
we should finish it nine months before
the launch
in this case it's
it's gonna be six months
yeah okay
because um
after we you know decide on the concept
and we kick off
there's a lot of other work we need to
do right
it's a comp it's a complex
piece by piece process that has to fit
sort of together like a puzzle otherwise
you're going to be delayed
because basically
even if you have to finalize that design
six to nine months before you end up
getting into those stages of testing
designs you've already thought of maybe
like
right after you've just you know
revealed the phone a year before so
that's it almost requires like a future
it requires a vision of what you want in
the future long before you're actually
going to share it so that is exactly
really interesting to note
that's why it's really helpful to have a
product strategy so when you're building
a roadmap you make sure that you always
follow this strategy that you built
awesome well look i'm i appreciate the
time and uh and all the info and
background on how these phones come
together i feel like i've learned a lot
i'm hoping everyone who's listening has
also learned a lot about how this stuff
works but uh anything any closing words
any final parting teasers for nord you
want to drop on us before we get out of
here
i'm really just really excited to see uh
what everybody thinks about the product
when this video drops it's only a couple
of days left to the launch so
we're really excited and a little bit
anxious here
um so here's hoping that everything goes
well so that's been it again full
episode is on the waveform podcast if
you want to listen to all of it we go
into much greater detail but i'm
actually curious now for you
does this affect the way you think about
smartphones
and those compromises at all like now
that you know nfc costs four bucks now
that you know an ip certification will
be 15 extra dollars on the bill of
materials or that it might cost twice as
much for a good amoled display versus
lcd how does this change the way you
think about smartphones we can have a
discussion in the comments section below
either way thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
you